Here is a concrete example of an
extension. It's a fairly standard implementation, let's say
of Unix operating system, but it is implemented
as an extension on top of the spin.
Here is a more fun example. A client
server application that is implemented directly on top
of spin as an extension. In other words,
there is no operating system. A display client
uses an extension interface to implement the
functionality for displaying video that is going to
be sent by a video server. So both of these are extensions on top of basic
spin, and provide exactly the functionality that
is needed for the video server application. And
the bounding box here is showing spin and
the extensions thereof. And similarly the bounding box
here is showing spin and the extension thereof. In this case
it is an entire operating system, in this case it is just
the client of the video server. And in this case it is
just the video server itself as an extension on top of spin.